[Music]
mobbed by fans as he arrived at court
johnny depp was an hour late for his
libel trial the final day of his team's
case against the sun newspaper
witnesses included a prominent
campaigner in the metoo movement
catherine kendall one of the first women
to accuse harvey weinstein of sexual
harassment
in text messages to a sun newspaper
reporter she said she'd been misquoted
i never meant to be in an article that
called johnny depp a wife beater she
said
i told you that i didn't know that to be
true at all i've heard several times
that she
in fact was abusive to him a secret
recording by mr depp's ex-wife amber
heard was played in court
of a meeting between her and her
interior designer laura devonier
she told ms heard she'd felt manipulated
by mr depp's lawyers into giving a
statement
you know i didn't know any of this
knowledge beforehand
i mean it was literally afterwards you
you always hid it from me
it's not your fault you didn't know i
hid it from everyone else i know
what people do a friend of johnny depp
isaac baroosh
also gave evidence describing photos of
injuries to amber heard as
phony baloney he says she was trying to
extort and blackmail him
and we heard an account from one of mr
depp's bodyguards travis mcgivern
of amber heard throwing a can of red
bull at the actor spitting at him
and punching him in the eye ms heard
claims that she was attacked
johnny depp suspected his wife was
having an affair with spacex ceo
elon musk a concierge described how mr
musk
visited mishurd often late at night and
always when mr depp was absent
next week amber heard will tell her side
of the story as super fans show support
for johnny depp on the street outside
it's his legacy and reputation at risk
adele robinson sky news at the high
court